Hey what's up it's
it's me you boy
markiplier and I
[Music]
it's me you boy
markiplier here with the first day of
the tour and the very first markiplier
shitty daily vlog cool we gotta go
because we're in Amsterdam right now but
we have to make our way to you have to
make our wits and silver oh really
yeah don't you know how to queue just
Americans hand come on be doing daily
vlogs all the way they're going to be
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
what are you talking about this you
don't know you don't know how sweet this
angle alright you know it was a man
that's not vlog that's a documentary hey
guys hey guys welcome to my super-sweet
shitty vlog we're going to Tilburg
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
how many people use a camcorder to vlog
[Music]
I did a sweet artistic shot yeah it was
pretty good oh yeah happy Valentine's
Day
not you
[Laughter]
[Music]
dude fresh all right we're always in
Tilburg we've already made our first
fatal travel mistake nobody brought
water so I assume we're gonna die in
short order
we were not prepared for this we were
not prepared for the rigors of the
Netherlands wait your next to be I'm
hoping one day that stem-cell research
will advance to the point where we can
make burgers of ourselves and eat only
us so I need a burger burger Wednesday
work that's me all right fam fam we're
here so this is the place there it is
covered in what seems to be CDs just
another classic place we're gonna wreck
with our presents anyway finally go into
rehearse it shows slightly different
than it was we have to have
intermissions in Europe for some reason
because our show is just so [ __ ] good
but they can't handle 90 minutes of
unadulterated us
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
I did keto from him and Sam is crazy
gives you a headache in the first you
know 3 days we get over that and then
he's crazy
bacon water first
[Music]
I've been talking about that joke since
before the tour for your tour let me
tell you about the Tilburg ghost all
right so we're gonna what we're gonna do
is we're gonna rehearse and then we're
gonna do a show
[Laughter]
tract standards are a little lower in
yawns all right
what up eat your boy now here's how we
gonna do we're going over up to the
stage and we're about to do us some
improv we're getting ready for the show
the show is not gonna blow and we ain't
gonna show nobody no bad and we a go go
out there and we don't do good okay move
move move out of the way all right it is
day flippin one I already have a sore
throat
[ __ ] travel do it to you every single
time you can't survive against it it
just kills you got done with her so we
killed it smash it out of the park next
up is lunch and I actually got to
practice my songs I suppose hey I just
got done with my acoustic performance
for the VIP set I didn't record any of
it here's a little here's not what Amy
hold this
[Music]
[Music]
I'm gonna check in with the boys yo yo
how you feel by the show tonight man
this lens is dirty all right there you
go go for it now what do you think of
our chances tonight come on oh yeah what
about your dick have to say about that
get queer you have to say about that you
were the penis it's his hand I'm done
go see pictures of chica go look up
pictures of chica on my Instagram and
like my Twitter go look at those those
are real cute okay all right love you
bye